lap was always a central part of that
family gathering hi i'm arya and i'm
going to be showing you today how to
make lab lab is kind of like a meat
salad from laos it's kind of the
national dish in a way it can be made
out of chicken pork beef duck fish today
we'll be making one out of pork so as a
quick tip usually sticky rice is cooked
in a bamboo steamer but if you don't
have one you can use a regular steel
steamer but you just line the top with
parchment paper and that's where you put
the rice on top of
another quick tip is when you're
toasting your rice make sure to keep
moving the pan so that it evenly toasts
the rice and so it's not just brown on
one side a very very important element
of lap is the ground rice and in order
to achieve this you could use a spice
grinder or as well as a pestle mortar
the beauty of lot to me is that it is an
everyday dish it's a dish for the common
people it's a dish for the wealthy it's
a dish for everyone it's something that
everyone can come around together and
eat it's a quick meal it's eating at
room temperature so it doesn't have to
be heated up it's a perfect dish for any
type of day all year round so i actually
never lived in laos but i did grow up in
the north of thailand in the north of
thailand there's cuisine called isan
cuisine which is influenced a lot by lao
cuisine and when i was in thailand i
actually spent some time in a monastery
as a monk the only way you eat as a monk
is when you're given arms by the local
villagers who will give you food when
you walk around the local village and
and very often that dish would be locked
so lap was a very common thing we would
eat in the monastery you'd take it back
to the monastery and you would share it
with the rest of the monks what i
personally love about lap is not just
the textures and the flavors but the way
it kind of connects me with my heritage
because i didn't grow up in laos but for
me whenever we would go back to visit or
whenever we met with family around the
world lap was always a central part of
that family gathering so i was actually
born in san francisco because both my
parents although they grew up in laos
they had to leave the country for
different reasons my father left to
france from a young age and my mother
fled the country in the 70s during a
socialist takeover because my
grandfather was an ambassador and they
were granted amnesty here in the u.s
because of this we never actually moved
back to laos while i was young we would
visit to see family or some of the
family that would still remain there my
background i'm very much a third culture
kid because i grew up in cultures and
countries that weren't really my own but
it was great because not only was i able
to learn and explore these different
cultures but at the same time of course
my parents made sure to teach me a loud
culture through cuisine this recipe is a
great way for me to connect with that
part of me this entire process was
really cool for me because not only am i
able to learn how to make such an
important loud dish but i was able to
connect with my mom throughout this
entire process checking to make sure i
was doing things right cutting the
radish right making sure that all these
different elements like the ground rice
were incorporated to make sure this was
as authentic as possible for anyone
that's growing up the way i did where
you're bouncing from country to country
or just in a country that's not your own
sometimes you can feel a little lost a
little alienated if you're moving
country to country you can feel like
you're losing friends and you're being
uprooted all the time but looking back
i'm so thankful for it and i think that
my advice would be to just embrace it
when you realize how lucky you were to
not just have one home but many homes
oh yes
[Music]
you